hi thank you all for joining us today
we're really thrilled to have the
opportunity to share with you our recent
work integrating Jupiter notebooks into
our civic analytics data science
platform there's me and that's saga my
name is Laurie Ike I'm a senior product
manager at Civic analytics I'm going to
talk about our motivations behind our
notebooks integration and how the need
for collaboration became a really real
problem for us as well as our process
towards finding the most appropriate
solution hi my name is Sonya commandery
I'm a tech lead at civis analytics and
I'm going to talk about our engineering
process going from scoping the feature
to building it and getting feedback from
users and I'm also going to use a really
bad analogy later in my talk so keep an
ear out for that so this is the service
platform since analytics started as a
data science consultancy based in
Chicago spun out of the 2012 Obama
re-election campaign and it's evolved
into also being a data science product
company the civics platform is a toolkit
that we built for our own data science
work and it's now also available to our
clients we learned firsthand that
spending a lot of time doing DevOps work
to set up an environment is really not
the best use of a data scientist time so
we built this platform where data
scientists can work the way they want to
work but backed by scalable Amazon
redshift cloud resources and in a high
security environment our platform is
essentially just software as a service
with both browser and API support so it
facilitates easy collaboration on data
science teams our users are typically
solving data science problems for
companies that want insights on their
customers using our platform they unify
their customer list with our data build
models to gain insights on their
existing customers or to find new target
customers and to create reports about
these insights data scientists can
import data to redshift enhance their
data with civis data interact with data
using sequel r and python and run
scripts and docker containers which
allows them to connect to any code in a
git repository our users can also build
automated workflows from scripts and
publish their own apps and reports some
users love working in the browser UI
while others use of its platform
entirely through the API with our Python
and our API code clients
we also make collaboration very easy
with sharing and cloning and all the
work done in our platform can be
organized into projects this makes it
really easy to keep a set of import
scripts matching jobs models reports all
together in one place and then you can
just share that collection of work with
your teammates so now I'm going to shift
gears a little bit and tell you a story
about some work we did last year we were
presented with a pretty challenging
client problem we were on an extremely
tight deadline and the data we had to
work with was noisy chaotic and really
disorganized there was a team of five
civis data scientists and they don't
head first into this project and started
tackling different pieces of the
solution so these data scientists all
preferred doing their exploratory
analysis in Python so they were all
using Jupiter notebooks they were using
these on their laptop so they get
iterate and build out their work however
when it came time to reconvene and put
this project back together they hit a
huge wall their notebooks environments
were all different their note before all
looking at different pieces of the data
that they had to like pull on to their
local machines they couldn't really
interact with the original data source
and redshift and it was really difficult
to keep everybody working sink this the
inherently independent nature of working
in a jupiter notebook was was blocking
them from successfully collaborating on
this project the team did end up
delivering an on-time solution but it
required a lot of late nights and a lot
of unnecessary stress and headaches and
we came out of this project knowing that
we really needed a better solution so as
our product management team researched
this problem deeper we serviced more
things about notebooks that were
problematic for data scientists so as we
already learned collaboration is
extremely difficult you have to be
working from the same environment the
same library is installed and pointing
at the same data sets at service our
data is stored in Amazon redshift so no
book users would have to pull data from
the cloud on to their local machines and
another problem we saw was that these
notebooks were limited to the compute
power of our company laptops if somebody
wanted to do something particularly
complex with their data they'd have to
keep their laptop active in churning
throughout the entire process
well yes you can just build out your own
like notebook server environment to
avoid this problem it's really a tedious
work around that you shouldn't have to
do as
data scientist to our team it seemed
like the workarounds to enable
collaboration and scalability were the
biggest pain points for notebook users
they were really just logistic barriers
keeping them from the meat of this
actual data science work so we knew that
our data science platform already
provided the shared workspace that was
so often needed by these teams of data
scientists so maybe if we added a
notebooks tool we could maybe give our
users in iterative exploratory
environments that uses a variety of
different languages and also alleviate
their existing notebooks pain points so
in the end we decided that the problem
that we were trying to solve how might
we include a don't book product in our
data science platform so this is really
vague this question is pretty open-ended
and there's a lot of different avenues
we can take to solve it do Purdue
notebooks are really popular but there's
also other notebook products or we could
build something on build something on
our own that just fits this iterative
and exploratory environment for
requirement that we have but the main
thing we had to make sure was that any
solution we ended up taking really takes
advantage of these collaboration tools
that we already have inside of our data
science platform so to help us figure
out the best solution we decided to
conduct a design sprint design sprints
are awesome this is a product research
technique popularized by Google Ventures
what happens is a small team spends four
or five days together working on a
really focused problem in our case it
was the how might a notebook product fit
into our data science platform they work
through ideas they make decisions and
eventually they build a prototypes on
the final day of the design sprint a
prototype is tested with users to
validate whether or not this idea should
become a reality
so you'll see a typical product
development cycle follows this idea bill
launch learned pathway what a design
sprint really enables is you can skip
the build and launch it's just idea and
learn and you just get to the learning
much much faster so for this sprint we
assembled a small team with a really
wide variety of expertise we had an
applied data scientist who uses
notebooks on a regular basis for client
work from there we could get an
understanding
of how our platform that looks to fit
into everyday usage with data in
redshift we included a vs Rd lead this
is a person who was a part of the team
that I spoke about earlier that had
struggled with collaboration we knew
that she'd really help us ensure that
our notebook solution definitely fits
this necessity to be able to work in a
team we included an engineering lead guy
as our implementation expert he was
there to make sure that our ideas were
technically feasible and that our
engineering team would be able to
support whatever solution that we landed
on we had a designer whose expertise in
user experience and prototyping was
essential in building that mock-up that
we can confidently test on our users at
the end of the week and we included me
the product manager that my job in this
room was to understand the competitive
landscape and also our user personas and
then translate and prioritize the sprint
outcomes into engineering work so by the
end of the Sprint we'd learn quite a bit
about how data scientists envision using
notebooks within the context of our
platform these outcomes really turned
into user stories that fit a handful of
themes the most important ones that we
found users would like to work in a
familiar environment iterating on
exploratory work is the way that
notebooks are most often used our users
need to be able to scale up their
computing resources and that
collaboration must be possible and
hopefully painless so to dig in a little
to each of these things throughout our
pre sprint research in our prototype
testing our users made it very clear
that Jupiter is a recognizable product
even users who were not familiar with
our platform it seemed very comfortable
once they jumped in and saw a Jupiter
notebook that was a product that they
know so we made the decision to use
unfortunate or notebooks rather than
making major changes to Jupiter or using
some other flavor of notebooks this is
because of diverse popularity and
familiarity for our users we also really
like that added bonus that we might be
able to contribute back to the Jupiter
project if down the road we add some
really cool new features that other
people might want
so looking into the iteration and
exploration theme when we dug into why
data scientists like notebooks it's
really clear that users have to be able
to use R and Python to be able to
explore their data and to see some
outcomes before writing a more robust
production script while this is already
accomplished with local notebooks using
notebooks in our platform as this
element of closeness to data when you're
when you're working with your data in
our platform you can see your datasets
right there in redshift right next year
right next to your notebook
it just feels closer and so you can also
load data into pandas or our data frames
with our Python and our API clients our
users don't have to don't want to have
to bother with API keys or move data
around what we found is that by hosting
notebooks in our platform and giving
easy access to their redshift data we
could give our users a better experience
for iteration and exploration than they
were already having under local
notebooks and on the theme of scaling a
data science work that's more and more
complex jobs to take more and more
compute power to actually execute by
hosting Oh books in our platform we can
move job execution off of the local
machine and into the cloud which allows
the user to just hit go pack up take
their computer home for the day and let
their jobs just turn up in the cloud all
night rather than sit and wait for the
laptops essentially finish running the
job and our user types really confirm
that you don't utilizing cloud computing
resources rather than local resources
would make it a lot easier to run more
complex jobs
additionally we found that giving users
the ability to scale up the compute
power on their notebooks on demand would
add more flexibility for how they really
want to work they be able to expand the
resources in a way that just was not
possible with the local machine and this
is my favorite user story theme which is
collaboration it's great to work
together in this past a lot of data
scientists worked in the silo a data
science scientist might have been the
only member of a data team and really
not needed to share their work at all
except for with stakeholders or managers
or people who aren't really doing the
data science but data is the future and
across industries now data teams are
growing data scientists have an
increasingly greater needs
to share their work so we knew going
into this design sprint that our users
were interested in using notebooks as
part of a team but that so far this was
really difficult to accomplish when we
showed our prototype to existing
platform users they immediately caught
on to this idea that they'd be able to
use notebooks as a team rather than as
individuals they immediately had all of
these great ideas on how they could use
their notebooks they were asking for
giving their teammates on on board for
the testing process they were building
out training documentation building out
reports they were building out like
examples for how to use new features
within the platform it was really cool
and it seemed like the ideas just were
popping out of their heads is just
endless fantastic so we realized these
user interviews that we needed to make
sure that our platform our platform
notebooks really included all of these
sharing features that already exist for
other jobs in our platform enabling
notebooks with this shared team
environment that we already have was
going to allow users to jump seamlessly
from iterating and exploring their data
into delivering insights and sharing
insights with their co-workers and they
could do it all from the same tool it's
really cool so the other thing that
users really wanted on the same vein was
to be able to operate on the same
notebook together or clone and teammates
notebook to branch some work they wanted
to have also a read-only view of the
notebook so anybody can view that
current state of a notebook without
actually having to run it the way to
kind of deliver value without letting
somebody touch your stuff so what's cool
is that these outcomes as a whole gave
us a pretty good idea of what our end
product might include so now I'm going
to turn over the mic to Sangha who's
going to talk about how our engineering
team implemented the ideas all right can
you guys hear me all right how many
people are waiting for the analogy
couple people great all right so we had
an ambitious goal which was to be able
to launch Python 3 notebooks in our
platform with that read-only preview
that Laurie was talking about and for
the rest of the talk I'm going to be
talking about our process for
implementing this feature how we build
to such a large feature in
to our platform and some of the
technical choices that we made along the
way and what I hope is that this will
help you to understand our engineering
process maybe you maybe give you some
tips so you can take back to your own
organization and provide some insights
into just how hard it is to build
something like this and how much work is
involved in designing a large feature so
at a high level there are three steps to
engineering a feature first you want to
scope it
so that's figuring out what the
requirements are and how much work will
be needed to satisfy those requirements
then you need to actually build it which
compared to these other two steps is
actually the easy part and then you want
to show it to users and get feedback so
you know what to build next
and ideally you want this loop to be as
fast as possible so you can continually
incorporate feedback from users into
your design so the notebooks feature
that we wanted to build is actually
pretty huge so how do you actually scope
a large multi-month project the answer
is that you should never do this until
you get something in front of users and
get feedback you have no idea what you
should build we use the term MVP Minimum
Viable Product which means a small but
functional version of a large feature
and an MVP is the smallest thing that
you can build and show to users and
still learn something useful and if you
learn that what you did is completely
wrong that's okay because you didn't do
that much work to build it and you can
change it and build something that users
actually want and it's been empirically
shown that large projects are much less
successful than a chain of smaller
projects that actually do the same thing
so now that I've convinced you to build
an MVP how do you scope that so this is
our process for doing that so first we
start with the requirements that came
out of that design sprint then we add in
non-functional requirements so these are
the things that engineering care is
about but don't describe things that
maybe users are doing in the product so
things like security making sure that
it's scalable reliability things like
that so once we have all of those
requirements in mind we write out a
feature story and user stories and you
can think of these stories like
it's for writing out your requirements
that force you to enumerate what the
goal is and what the business
constraints are so these are this gets
you towards more precise specifications
of what your requirements are next we
enumerate all the work that's required
to satisfy these stories and all of the
dependencies for that work and finally
you want to arrange the work to get
feedback as quickly as possible so this
is how our white board looks midway
through the process so the writing on
the board has our feature story and the
post-its are the units of work that meet
that are needed to satisfy those stories
and once we're done we can reorder those
post-its in such a way that we can learn
as quickly as possible
so these post-its describe our entire
plan but our MVP is just going to be a
subset of these throughout this process
users are going to tell you what what
they really want and your plans are
going to get disrupted so all those
post-its a lot of them where you may not
end up doing but there's nothing wrong
with that for example when we did our
design sprint our users didn't express
much interest in our in their notebooks
because they were much more used to
doing things with our studio and our
markdown but when our our users saw
Python notebooks in platform they wanted
it and we realized we needed to move our
kernel support and Jupiter up on the
roadmap so next I'm going to talk about
what we built and not just the MVP that
we built but the full architecture so
these are the components of our
architecture there's Jupiter there's a
custom built authentication proxy which
we call the front door there's
containerized notebooks running on
kubernetes and then there's routing
using an open source product called
traffic and next I'm going to take a
technical deep dive into each of these
so an idea that you're going to hear
over and over again is security so we
take security very seriously at civis
and all of our architectural decisions
are made with security in mind from the
start users work with sensitive client
data in our platform and in their
notebooks so security is important and
usable security was the focus of my PhD
and I'm Bea I was the engineering lead
on this project so I was interested in
making
sure that we can make things more secure
but also do this without constraining
users and hopefully you'll see how that
plays out in our architectural decisions
so the first component of our
architecture is Jupiter and we chose
Jupiter like Laurie said because it's
the clear winner in the notebook
ecosystem this means that users can
bring their existing notebooks into our
implementation easily and also take them
out easily and one thing that's
important is that we use Jupiter without
modification we didn't fork it and this
meant that we were able to upgrade to
the latest version of Jupiter the day it
was released so the next component of
our architecture is our authentication
proxy so this X is the front door to
your notebook and the front door ensures
that only authorized users can get into
the notebook you can access your
notebooks from anywhere as long as you
have internet access
but unauthorized users won't be able to
get into the front door Jupiter does
have its own authentication mechanism
you can set a token or a password to get
into your notebook but both of these
mechanisms are persistent and what this
means is that no matter how long ago
someone got this URL if your notebook is
still running they can get they can
still get into it so in contrast our
proxy provides time-bound authentication
so when you access your notebook our
platform generates a URL that's only
good for 10 seconds and constantly
rotates so when you interact with our
notebook through our platform that
rotation is happening automatically in
the background our proxy also supports
multiple users where each user gets
different tokens that identify them so
you can share your running notebook with
other users if you want and they can
access it directly and we don't think
this would be a very common occurrence
since it's not actually supported by
Jupiter but if you need another pair of
eyes on something sharing a running
notebook is the fastest way to do it and
this would have come in really handy for
our data science team in the scenario
that Laurie talked about they would have
been able to iterate on work in their
notebook and share it amongst each other
and even though Jupiter doesn't support
it as long as they weren't both trying
to do things at the same time they could
have traded work among some
so and with the sharing features that
are in our platform you can also revoke
access to a notebook whenever you want
but the unsung benefit of having our own
authentication solution is a separation
of concerns Jupiter doesn't need to know
anything about our authentication system
and if Jupiter's implementation of
authentication changes it won't break
our implementation and our
implementation can actually be more
secure than Jupiter because we've broken
it out and we can reuse this
authentication proxy to front-door other
applications and we've already started
doing this internally so just to clarify
once you've been authorized to access a
notebook we get out of your way you just
have to keep our platform page open in
the background to maintain that
authorized rotating connection and then
you can open the notebook itself in a
new tab full screen open a terminal
inside of it and otherwise just interact
with it like you would local notebook so
the next component in our architecture
is kubernetes so you can think that we
have all of these houses that each
contain a notebook and then we have a
front door that protects access to those
houses and now we need to put all of
these houses somewhere and that's where
kubernetes does it organizes all of
these houses so it's kind of like the
suburbs so kubernetes is an open source
system for running and managing
containerized applications we use
kubernetes to run users notebooks and
kubernetes has some great abstractions
called pods and services for deploying
multiple containers so using pods and
services we can have the notebook and
the front-door deployed together and we
can specify that the notebook is not
accessible to the rest of the world and
it's only accessible through the front
door and there are two things about
kubernetes that really stood out for us
as we used it first it just works
if you've ever if you've ever tried to
learn about kubernetes you'll know that
it's very very complicated and there's a
lot of parts to it but amazingly once
you learn how to do things it all just
works we basically had no problems with
any of the core functionality it also
has a pluggable architecture and a
decent ecosystem of plugins there were a
few plugins that we need
in order to implement this system there
was just no way to make it work without
them and while they're not as easy to
use of the core components at least they
exist and we were able to make them do
what we want now the bad about
kubernetes is actually a security so as
I said we take security very seriously
but kubernetes security model doesn't
necessarily fit what we need the issue
is that kubernetes trusts all
applications that run on top of it it
wasn't designed around threats from the
inside so if you're using kubernetes to
host your internal services this is okay
or kind of okay but for us the fact that
malicious applications can take control
of the cluster if they need if they want
to and then possibly steal your data is
not okay so we have a few choices here
we could just not care and let you get
hacked and we're not going to do that we
could lock down what you could do in
your notebook and this is the approach
that Jupiter held cakes or we could lock
down the system that wraps your notebook
to contain the damage if someone does
something malicious so we chose to lock
down the surrounding system so we
isolate kubernetes resources per client
so the node that runs your notebooks
will never run another client's
notebooks this way if someone does run
malicious code in your notebook they can
only steal data from their own
organization
even with per client isolation
kubernetes will still honor requests
from internal applications so we also
have to use role based access control
which is a kubernetes plugin to lock
down cluster permissions further so
basically now we've got gated
communities for each client in our
suburbs this analogy working so far
great all right so now we've got all
these houses nicely arranged in
kubernetes but there's so many houses we
need a way to route everyone to the
right place to implement routing we
chose an open source tool called traffic
which is spelled like that it's like a
GPS for getting to the right house and
traffic is nice because it integrates
well with kubernetes when we deploy
notebook traffic automatically watches
events and
creates routes to the to the notebooks
themselves it's also deployable in a
high availability configuration you can
have multiple instances of traffic
running and they all share the same
route table so if one of them crashes
the rest of them can step in and route
you to your notebook and finally Jupiter
uses a protocol called WebSockets to
communicate between the browser and
server elements of Jupiter and many many
products like traffic that support
proxying don't support WebSockets or
don't support it very well traffic is
one of the few that does we've tried out
a couple others and we had issues with
WebSockets timing out so those are the
components of our architecture and an
obvious question might be why did we
build this ourselves instead of using
something like super hub which according
to this description does exactly the
thing that we want it's a single system
that allows multiple users to create
Jupiter notebooks so I'm going to
compare and contrast civis notebooks
with what you get with Jupiter hub and I
think this is useful because if you're
in the market for a multi-user notebook
system you're probably going to look at
Jupiter hub first and even if you aren't
familiar with you bird hub this
comparison should give you a better
understanding of what we've built so
this is a high-level diagram of Jupiter
hub you connect to a single hub server
which spawns notebooks for you to
connect to and that single Jupiter hub
server is a single point of failure you
can spawn lots of notebooks but there's
only one coordinating hub so that's
something that has no redundancy and
also doesn't easily scale Jupiter hub is
also built around a single user design
it doesn't have a way to share notebooks
between users or organize them into
projects or archive them or clone them
which are all sharing features of our
platform that we wanted to support I
also believe that real-time
collaboration in notebooks is right
around the corner literally it's right
around the corner there's a talk about
it tomorrow at 2:05 and McKinley so you
should check that out if you want to
know more and like I said our
architecture already supports routing an
authentication of multiple people to the
same notebook while Jupiter hub does not
and finally Jupiter help doesn't allow
for customization I want to point out
that I'm not picking on Jupiter Avior
even though it seems like I'm really
picking on Jupiter hub it's a really
great piece of software I just has
different benefits to what we want so
Jupiter hub recommends that the
administrator of the server decide what
packages are installed and then prevent
users from installing their own packages
and they do this for security reasons
and those are good reasons but we've
built a system with a very different
security architecture that doesn't have
this restriction we allow you to install
whatever packages you need into each
notebook and for those familiar with
docker we even allow you to bring your
own docker image if you need to
customize further so in summary our
gated community suburb architecture
gives you high availability no single
point of failure notebooks that are
built for sharing and collaboration so
they don't have a single user
orientation and a notebook system that
is highly secure we get flexible enough
to allow access by multiple users and
allows you to customize the environment
that you run your notebook in okay so
that was a very long discussion of how
we built the system then now let's get
back to the next step in the process
where we show what we've built to users
and get their feedback so remember we're
doing this because we want to make sure
that we're building the right thing once
we built an MVP we started showing our
MVP to users we had a weekly meeting
with engineers product and design and
internal internal notebook users that
was organized by Laurie where we showed
where we were and got feedback about
what we should change and we use
continuous delivery of service so
everything that we demoed was usable by
the people in the room so they could
give feedback during the meeting or they
could go play with the product after the
meeting and give us comments later and
they give you some sense of how we walk
their way towards a complete notebook
feature here is the general progression
of features and how we moved forward so
the first thing that we wanted people to
be able to do is create a notebook
within our platform then we supported
people uploading existing notebooks
then we allowed people to start
increasing the RAM and see
you that are allocated thinner to their
notebooks then we actually put in
authentication so up to this point in
the process we had a dummy front door
that just blindly trusted the first
person that walked up to it once we got
to this point and we realized okay we're
really doing notebooks and we want them
to be secure we put more effort into the
authentication at this point we also did
a design review of the feature as it is
as it was at that point and made changes
based on that review then we started to
add new features like allowing users to
change the installed packages and adding
support for the our kernel that I talked
about earlier so that's how we built
notebooks that are secure customizable
and collaborative into our platform and
questions how do we handle versioning so
right now we don't handle versioning
notebooks are sort of uploaded and
downloaded into our platform but
something that we're working on right
now is integration with git so that you
can upload and download your notebooks
into a git repo instead of into our
platform which stores them in s3 Oh
correct
so the notebook container is completely
ephemeral yes you go into a little bit
how you got scaling to work through how
the scaling works in kubernetes or
yeah so right now we actually just right
now we're at a point where our
kubernetes nodes are a single size
they're all 32 gig machines and by
default users are given two gigs of that
via docker so docker allows you to
specify m't the RAM and CPU that's
available and so by default they're
given two gigs of two gigs of RAM but
there is just a drop down right here a
little bit above here where they can
type in the RAM that they see that they
want and the amount of CPU units that
they want and so they can scale that all
the way up but another thing that we're
working on right now is allowing users
to select the instance size that backs
their notebook yeah so we don't
currently so I guess I should say I
don't know if Laurie said it we haven't
actually released notebooks yet the
external release target is end of
September so we don't currently support
once we support selecting the instance
that back to your notebook
then we'll have automatic support for
GPUs yes
and some code in that we are women
anyway
yeah so I can answer both of those
questions so the we already support
credentials in other parts of our
platform the way it works is you can
actually securely create credentials in
our platform and then via if you're
creating a script in our platform you
can say I want the script have access to
these credentials and they get loaded
into the environment that is generated
so when you so the way it would work in
notebooks is that those credentials
would appear as environment variables
that you could then read out of and the
way that we support credentials in
notebooks is using asymmetric encryption
so the web's once you create a
credential within our platform the web
servers can no longer read it it has to
go off to a more secure computer that
can then read those credentials and
construct the environment and then give
it to you the answer your second
question about packages right now you
could you could install packages in the
environment you have sudo in the
notebook so you can do whatever you want
but like the answer to the other
question is an ephemeral container so
it's going to go away when you stop the
server or when it times out but one
thing that you can do to to pre install
those is you can fork our docker image
and install the packages in that docker
image and then use that docker image in
your notebook oh and sorry I didn't
answer your question about the
monitoring that's also something that
we're working on right now is we do have
we have internal monitoring of all of
those resources and we're working on
exposing them to users
no questions
if you have any more questions please
come talk to us we have a booth out in
the hallway and we'll be around tomorrow
as well
[Applause]